[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 les deux et trois
juin prochain la tour mais les watts
revient à 50 ans en Yvelines pour en
parler avec nous je suis aujourd'hui
avec Pierre Michel Planchon coordinateur
à l'association metasos qui organise la
tour elewatts bonjour bonjour alors le
festival s'étend sur deux journées les
deux et trois juin 2023 quels sont les
objectifs de ce festival
les objectifs c'est avant tout de faire
la fête c'est surtout ça d'avoir ce
moment particulier fédérateur de faire
un petit peu bouger le un petit peu mais
voir beaucoup bouger le territoire quand
même et ouais de passer un super moment
voilà il fera beau au soleil début de
l'été plein air musique
c'est justement le choix de la date
c'est toujours des débuts juin
finalement que vous organisez ce
festival c'est voulu notamment pour ce
beau temps cette chaleur
quand même oui oui et aussi c'est
trouver cette petite place parmi tous
les festivals qui peut exister voilà
c'est les choix ne sont pas forcément
évident la première fois on avait tenté
vraiment tout début juillet mais plus
personne est dans le coin c'est déjà les
vacances c'est ça au fil des années la
tour met les watts est devenue un
festival presque incontournable un des
Yvelines les plus particulièrement à 50
ans en Yvelines comment se fait une
programmation d'un tel festival quels
sont vos ambitions lorsque vous
sélectionnez les artistes ou groupes qui
seront présents
l'ambition ça avant tout de faire
découvrir des artistes c'est surtout ça
le moteur
de la programmation du festival mais à
la fois la découverte mais aussi invité
des artistes un plus reconnus quand même
aussi de renom voilà pour avoir la
chance de les avoir près de chez soi
quand même donc ça c'est quand même
c'est incroyable
donc ouais j'ai la motivation propre
c'est de faire découvrir vraiment un
vivier d'artistes
de tout style de tout genre à la fois
des artistes donc un peu moins connus
émergents finalement et des artistes
déjà connus même international
internationalement tout à fait c'est
exactement ça alors on a pu parler de la
programmation du 2 juin dans une
précédente émission mais on va faire un
petit un petit rappel quand même
qu'est-ce qui attend les festivaliers le
2 juin au festival la tour meliwatts et
bien on pourra retrouver 6 artistes le 2
juin notamment tête d'affichement
dragora avec Istar Raccoon technobras
yolamiph et lgmix et le 3 juin 6
artistes seront également présents on va
revenir un petit peu sur sur chacun
d'eux on va commencer par biga Ranx son
écoute en extrait et on poursuit juste
après
[Musique]
donc pour la cinquième édition de la
tour mêlée watts pourquoi vouloir
programmer cet artiste
l'envie parce que c'est devenu un
artiste incontournable de la scène
reggae
justement il est de plus en plus plus en
plus connu finalement pas on va pas dire
essentiel mais une évidence d'avoir
d'avoir cet artiste à votre festival oui
ouais en partie puis c'est ça fait
partie aussi des artistes dont
que ce soit des bénévoles ou du public
qui nous ont c'est un nom qui est revenu
assez régulièrement et souvent aussi ces
dernières années on y avait pensé déjà
il y a quelques éditions
et du coup bah là cette année c'était
vraiment l'occasion voilà de le
programmer de les faire parce que c'est
vraiment devenu voilà un artiste assez
inconternable de cette scène française
reggae et on poursuit avec flox quel est
l'univers musical de cet artiste alors à
l'univers de flox lui voilà il va il est
assez riche et on est toujours dans le
reggae mais un peu le ce qu'on appelle
le nuragais un petit peu donc il y a
aussi cette pâte un petit peu
électronique avec des sons voilà assez
qui font partir quoi qu'il faut un petit
peu planer un peu atmosphérique tout ça
avec une petite touche électronique donc
ouais c'est il y a des artistes comme ça
c'est pas forcément facile à décrire
aujourd'hui voilà précisément le style
de musique parce que on emprunte un
petit peu de partout et donc voilà on
est assez de la matière bac un peu
nouvelle quoi finalement il y a pas un
seul genre il y a peut-être un genre qui
qui domine un petit peu dans la couleur
musicale mais finalement il y a
tellement de
voilà d'inspiration de de genre
différent que on fait un mix de tout ça
c'est du coup ça aussi que vous voulez
mettre en avant c'est ce mélange des des
styles voilà tout à fait et le Peuple de
l'Herbe sera également présent qu'est-ce
qui attend les festivaliers lors de
cette leur représentation incontournable
peuvent de l'herbe là ça fait des années
vraiment qu'on toute la France donc
groupe dub justement et comme on parlait
tout à l'heure sur le mélange des styles
pub de l'arbre c'est un très très bon
exemple parce qu'on peut avoir un album
qui est très interroque un autre ou si
on prend un hip-hop d'autres plus
oreiller ils ont un éventail assez large
et donc on est très content de pouvoir
les accueillir
sur le festival il nous reste encore
trois artistes et pas des moindres on va
écouter un extrait de bastong et on
poursuit juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baston donc le 3 juin au festival la
tournée des watts quelle est la
particularité de cet artiste
vous m'avez dit il y avait que de
l'audio là les auditeurs ou sur les
vidéos on ne voit pas l'artiste c'est ça
alors oui de toute façon on peut trouver
sur internet la particularité c'est
qu'il a construit en fait son instrument
de musique donc qui est une percussion a
donc avec des tubes en PVC et elles ont
ils jouent son nom baston il joue avec
des tongs donc en fait il crée ces
sonorités là vraiment avec ses
percussions cette pub en PVC et il est
tout seul et moi ça a été un découverte
il me semble en 2018 ou 2019 par hasard
et à titre personnel c'était vraiment
mon coup de coeur cet artiste et bah
super content de pouvoir programmer
l'accueillir et j'invite les gens déjà à
venir le découvrir en festival lorsque
je pense que le show va être
exceptionnel et surtout pour les
vraiment les curieux d'aller regarder
quelques vidéos sur YouTube parce que
c'est assez excellent quand même c'est
un artiste à écouter et à voir du coup
pour pour avoir tout son tout son
univers musical on va maintenant parler
de du Benco quel est l'univers justement
musical de cet artiste ça porte bien son
nom là on est dans la lignée artistique
du festival sur la programmation du
samedi on est dans le dub tout
simplement voilà et enfin Roja be c'est
comme ça qu'on le prononce pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas on va écouter un
extrait on poursuit juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et sur votre site internet vous proposez
également à ceux qui le souhaitent de
devenir bénévole lors de ce festival
alors qu'elles sont les missions des
bénévoles
elles sont multiples il y en a
différentes plusieurs et variées alors
l'émission bah on a la billetterie
vendre des billets on va avoir le
contrôle des entrées dans quelques vers
le public on a des buvettes donc servir
les festivaliers
on a les accueils accueillir les
artistes voilà tout un tas de missions
différentes très enrichissantes et on
imagine que vous pensez déjà une
nouvelle édition pour pour 2024 une
sixième édition tout à fait vous avez
déjà des des idées d'artistes oui ça
commence à avoir déjà quelques idées
pour penser de avoir un petit coup
d'avance à l'année prochaine comment
construire la programmation donc là on
note un petit peu les idées de côté
comme chaque année je vous le disais
tout à l'heure interview il y a quelques
artistes qu'on a cette année on avait
déjà parlé des idées comme ça qui
émergent ou des retours
parfois on nous parle des artistes
est-ce que tu as écouté un tel c'est
nouveau et ça sera beaucoup ça serait la
surprise pour pour l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup Michel Planchon d'avoir
été avec nous sur sensation le festival
la tourmie les watts c'est donc du 2 au
3 juin prochain à 50 ans en Yvelines et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]